we saw Jalen Ramsey get what he wanted
in Jacksonville he had a back injury and
he ultimately was able to finagle a
trade to the Rams in Cincinnati it could
be that something similar is happening
but I think they capped that it's mutual
I think that AJ Green who has an ankle
injury that goes back to training camp I
think that he wants to stay off the
field until he's potentially traded to
another team the deadlines coming up in
just about 11 days and I also think the
Bengals want to keep him off of the
field until they can trade him he's in
the last year of his contract
they're probably not gonna give him
anything close to market value because
they never do with anyone they don't
like using the franchise tag I think the
Bengals want to trade him Green wants to
stay healthy they wanted to be healthy
and he says he has a little ways to go
to return from his ankle injury the
little ways to go is whenever I'm traded
to another team I'm gonna be healthy
enough to play
yeah healthy right the next day boom my
ankles feeling a lot better I agree with
you Mike I think that the Bengals are
gonna doing the right thing here by
playing a little you know safe like who
is ankle we got to make sure because
this is a no brainer to trade him when
you have a horrific team when you need
draft picks when you need draft capital
to rebuild everything if they don't
trade them it's kind of like the
Redskins right now when they're do they
just basically are holding on to trent
williams and you're saying what is going
on here some of these teams that have no
chance of making the playoffs that have
no chance of maybe even winning a game
you need to trade your pieces right now
strip it down and build it back up with
some draft capital because there's a lot
of teams out there that think they are a
couple couple guys away from making the
Superbowl making the championship game
and they will pay a nice price for it
the question is are the Bengals
competent enough to tank right
dysfunctional things yeah are the
Bengals confident enough know they need
to do look they need to do something
they got other guys to here's the thing
once you sense that the Bengals are in
sale mode you don't have to put the sign
in the yard people are gonna start
calling you up and making you offers I
mean is someone gonna call up and make
an offer for Geno Atkins korte Glen
seems to be on the way out there's
something weird going
there is he returns from a concussion
tension between him and the team he was
fine $200,000 for conduct detrimental so
that there's there's some stuff there's
some real dysfunction going on with
these bengals and it may be time for
them to start turning current assets
into future draft picks in the hope that
they can eventually turn this thing
around oh by the way they got their
third home game coming up they had
20,000 empty seats at the last one and
that was the official number unofficial
it was probably thirty who's gonna go to
to see the Bengals play the Jaguars in
Cincinnati on Sunday
so who's trading for him go quickly I
may be Packers Patriots Patriots
interests hatreds or Packers but I think
it'd be the Patriots it it always has
felt like that's the fit for AJ Green
and they need a guy we talked about last
week who can draw a double coverage and
that would be AJ Green
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports